-Welcome to the show. Thank you
so much for being here.
I appreciate it.
-Thanks for having me.
-Yeah, this is a big --
a big weekend for you,
which is interesting to me.
I did not know this.
Your goddaughter hosted
"Saturday Night Live."
-Yes, she did! Zozo.
-Zoe Kravitz is your...
-Zoe Kravitz. Yeah.
-...is your goddaughter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mm-hmm. She killed it.
She killed it.
-She was fantastic.
-Yeah.
-We have a picture
of you and --
This is you and Lisa
and Baby Zoe.
-Oh, yeah. Well, you can't
really tell it's her, though.
-No, you can't tell.
Yeah, that's Zoe right there.
-Take our word.
-Exactly, yeah.
-And why I'm wearing a towel
on my head, I do not know.
-Yeah.
-I must've been chilly.
-Is this from, like,
"A Different World"?
Is that where you met?
-Yeah.
Well, we met before
"A Different World," actually.
-Oh, you did? So you've
been friends for a while.
-Yeah, we met in -- Yeah, in --
like, an acting workshop.
-Did Zoe ask for any advice
on how to host?
You've hosted
"Saturday Night Live."
-I did, many moons ago.
And she doesn't need any advice.
She's got it.
-She's just so cool.
-I mean, I was there
to cheer her on, of course.
-I ask her advice on anything.
I'm like, "Zoe,
just tell me how to be cool."
-I ask her for advice.
-Yeah, exactly.
-It's the other way around.
-I saw that yesterday marked
the 30th anniversary of
"My Cousin Vinny," which is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
One of your great films
that we all love.
When you're doing that --
When you do that movie,
when you were filming it,
did you have any idea
it would be that big of a hit
or that you would win an Oscar?
-No. [ Laughs ] I was just happy
to have a job.
-[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
Who is the person who thinks,
"I'm going to win an Oscar"?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-What kind of cajones
are you walking around with?
-Yeah, exactly. But it became
the biggest movie ever.
I mean, I think Vice President
Kamala Harris
said that
that's her favorite movie.
-Kamala Harris said that?
-Yes.
That's her favorite movie.
"My Cousin Vinny." Loves it.
They teach it in colleges --
in law-school classes.
-That I knew. That part I knew.
Yes, a lot of --
Many a lawyer have kind of
used that line on me.
-Did they ever ask you
come in and, like, speak?
-They ask me
to come in and speak.
They ask me other things.
-Yeah, that's wild. Yeah, yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-You've been -- You've been --
You've won and you've been
nominated for many, many awards.
But there is an honor that
I'm not sure if you know about.
There's a sandwich
named after you.
The world-famous
Lioni's deli in Brooklyn.
-Oh, really?
-The Marisa Tomei.
-I don't know that.
-Well, it's a very
exclusive club.
-[ Laughter ]
-So, on the sandwich is --
tell me if you like this --
fried eggplant.
-I like it.
-Fresh mozzarella.
-Love it.
-Bread crumbs.
-And mushroom stuffing.
-Not in a sandwich. Ohh.
-No mushroom stuffing?
-I'm disappointing
the Lioni's crew, I guess.
-No. Not a mushroom fan?
-Well, I like --
What about yourself?
-I do not like mushrooms.
I don't like mayonnaise, either.
-Oh, yeah...palate.
-Mushrooms and mayonnaise,
that's the only thing I don't --
Yeah, I don't enjoy those. Yeah.
Well, if we could
talk to those guys --
I figured
if you've never heard about it,
maybe you've never tried it.
I got one with
no mushrooms on it.
-Ohh.
-I got two of them actually.
I figured you could try
your own Marisa Tomei
on "The Tonight Show."
Marisa Tomei eating
a Marisa Tomei.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
♪♪
Do you have napkins for us
and everything?
Do we have a napkin?
-Oh, I do.
-I feel like this
is going to be awkward.
-[ Muffled ] No...
Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's fan-- What do you think?
-I have to lean over
with a sandwich this big.
I, like, can't do it,
like, right here.
I'm gonna make a mess.
-No, you can barely even talk
when you have a bite.
Can we talk about
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"?
-Yes. Yeah.
-You were fantastic in this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really -- You're always --
You're great in all of them.
It's made almost -- I know.
It made almost $2 billion
worldwide.
I mean, it is a giant movie.
It's the third-highest
grossing movie in history.
-It's so cool. It's so cool.
It's really a cool thing
to be a part of.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But it's a great movie, too.
I loved every single
second of it.
You play May Parker.
I love -- I love you.
I love Tom Holland.
I love Zendaya.
I couldn't get enough of every
single person in this movie.
I go, "I don't want it to end.
I want it to just keep
going on and on."
Is it tough to do those movies
knowing that you can't spoil
anything or talk about anything?
-Well, yes, at first it is,
because you have to sign
a lot of things
and it's all under secrecy.
Friends will ask.
Or family members
will ask about it.
-So you're happy it's out.
-I'm happy it's out.
I'm happy it's out now.
And I don't have to keep
that secret anymore.
-Yeah.
I mean, I wouldn't bother you
with questions, like,
if I saw you on the street.
-You wouldn't?
-No.
I'd just be like, "I'm cool."
-Would you just like --
-I wouldn't do it.
Because I already know
the thing.
The answer is, "Jimmy,
don't make me do this," yeah.
So I wouldn't do it.
And then after seeing it,
wow, there's some spoilers.
-There are some spoilers.
Yes. Yeah.
But maybe a few people
don't know yet.
So we can't --
we still can't talk about it.
-We still can't t-- Yeah.
Can we not talk about --
-Mnh-mnh-mnh-mnh-mnh-mnh-mnh!
-Can we talk about the --
-We can talk about mnh-mnh --
-Can we talk about that?
-Yeah, we can talk about that.
-We can?
-If we want to.
[ Laughter ]
I have no idea
what he's talking about.
-The fact that
there is a multiverse.
-Oh, yes.
There is a multiverse.
-Okay. We can say that.
-Yes.
-Yeah, I don't want to ruin it
for any fans out there.
-Right, yes.
There is a multiverse.
-If you haven't been
to the movies --
-That was part of the secrecy,
though. That's true.
That was part of the secrecy
originally.
Now a lot of people know.
-Yeah.
But the thing was,
if anyone asked me about it,
I would have nothing --
I don't understand
the multiverse, myself.
-[ Laughter ]
-So you couldn't spoil it.
You'd be like,
"I don't know what it is."
-Our wonderful director, Jon,
and I'm like,
"And so where am I now?
Okay, well, can you explain it
to me one more time?"
-[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Well, knowing that
there is a multiverse --
-Yeah, what do you think --
Are you done with the sandwich?
-[ Laughter ]
-No, I can go for it.
I actually really --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Now...
[ Muffled ]
Now...multiverse...
[ Both mumbling ]
-Yeah.
-Do you think that --
[ Laughter ]
Do you think
that you would ever do --
Would May Parker be
in a multiverse thing?
Would you ever want
to do something with --
-Yeah, I would love to come back
and be part of that --
I want to be --
-Like, a different movie?
-Yeah.
-You would do it?
There's history there, too.
May Parker hooks up
with Ant-Man in one of --
Well, I mean, she's
a stand-alone character,
of course.
-Yes, of course.
-But there are more avenues
to explore.
-All right. I'm going to
root for that right now.
-Is there anything in my teeth?
-Let me see. I will tell you.
No, you look beautiful.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Marisa Tomei,
not the sandwich,
"Spider-Man: No Way Home."
Take a look.
-I just feel so dumb.
I didn't realize
you were miserable.
-No, it was really fun.
That's why --
You know,
that's why they call it a fling.
And we flung.
-It was fun.
I could have been more fun.
I can be fun.
-We'll hang out again.
-Wait. When do you think?
[ Objects clattering ]
I should see what that is.
-No. No, no, no, no.
-This is what I do.
-He's always coming and going.
It's not --
-Peter.
-Oh, no.
-Oh, God.
-Peter?
-I don't know what to do!
-Peter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Marisa Tomei, everybody!
"Spider-Man: No Way Home"
is available on digital
starting tomorrow.